37% من الفتيات المراهقات اللاتي تتراوح أعمارهن بين 13 و15 عامًا
تعرضن لعُري غير مرغوب فيه خلال
أسبوع على Instagram، أنت تعرفين عنه من الذي
طردك أيها السيناتور، ولهذا السبب نقوم
ببناء جميع الأدوات التي فعلها أيها السيناتور،
لا أعتقد أن هذا هو من فعلك  حريق،
لن أجيب على ذلك لأنك
لم تطرد أي شخص، صحيح أنك لم
تتخذ أي إجراء مهم، ومن
المناسب التحدث عنه مثل
قرارات IND، هل تعرف من الذي يقف
خلفك، لديك عائلات من
جميع أنحاء البلاد الذين  الأطفال
إما أصيبوا بأذى شديد أو رحلوا ولا تعتقد أنه من
المناسب
الحديث عن الخطوات التي اتخذتها حقيقة
أنك لم تطرد شخصًا واحدًا دعني
أسألك هذا دعني أسألك هل قمت
بتعويض أي منهم  الضحايا آسفون، هل
عوضتم أيًا من الضحايا،
هؤلاء الفتيات هل عوضتمهن،
لا أصدق، فلماذا
لا تعتقدون أنهم يستحقون بعض
التعويض عما فعلته منصتكم،
المساعدة في خدمات الاستشارة، المساعدة
في التعامل مع القضايا  أن
خدمتك تسببت في أن مهمتنا هي
التأكد من أننا نبني أدوات للحفاظ على
سلامة الأشخاص، هل ستعوضهم، أيها السيناتور،
وظيفتنا وما نأخذه على
محمل الجد هو التأكد من أننا نبني
أدوات رائدة في الصناعة، تجدها ضارة،
خذها  خارج الخدمات لكسب المال
وبناء الأدوات التي تمكن الآباء،
لذلك لم تتخذ أي إجراء، ولم
تتخذ أي إجراء، ولم تطرد أي شخص،
ولم تعوض ضحية واحدة،
دعني أسألك هذا، دعني أسألك  أنت هنا،
هناك عائلات الضحايا هنا اليوم، هل
اعتذرت للضحايا؟
أود أن تفعل ذلك الآن، حسنًا، إنهم
هنا، أنت على التلفزيون الوطني، هل
ترغب الآن في الاعتذار للضحايا
الذين تضرروا من
برنامج مشكلتك؟  لهم
الصور، هل تودون الاعتذار
عما فعلتموه لهؤلاء الأشخاص الطيبين
[تصفيق]
ليمروا بالأشياء التي
عانت منها عائلاتكم،
ولهذا السبب استثمرنا الكثير
وسنواصل القيام بالصناعة مما يسمح ببذل
الجهود لأه  للتأكد من أنه لا أحد
يضطر إلى المرور بأنواع الأشياء
التي تشتهر بها